I'd like to also touch on a subject that
I think many doctors and health
organizations are avoiding talking about
and that's how protests are affecting
Cova 19 numbers if you know me at all I
am NOT a fan of fear-mongering you've
heard me call out the media time and
time again about the fact that they're
only after clicks and viewership with
the type of fear-mongering they put out
but I think it's about time that I fear
monger you a little bit I gave us so
much credit as a nation in the beginning
I would go on nationwide TV shows and
say there's so much unity around kovat
and now I don't know what happened over
these last few weeks what we through
social distancing out the window we
through masks out the window and we're
no longer being alert we're no longer
being proactive and what's happening
Kovac cases are spiking people are dying
and the second wave isn't even here yet
18 states are experiencing new highs of
kovat 19 cases six states have a spike
greater than 50% in their cases this is
a huge problem folks because the way we
control Kovan right now is by being
responsible both you and me and that
means keeping six feet away from others
that means wearing a mask at all times
where you're encountering other people
recently I took a walk around New York
City and I saw bars open
I saw people standing next to each other
talking with no masks in groups of 50 we
can't do this because the more we do it
the more people are gonna suffer
especially because we don't have a
vaccine if you think it's bad now it can
get a lot worse for the fall many people
have asked me if vaccines are the answer
to Cova 19 and while I have high hopes
for the vaccine I also have a few
reservations doctor pouchy NIH CDC have
said that the proposed timeline if
everything goes well early 2021 and
that's the fastest we've ever had a
vaccine so I'm hopeful it comes out then
it's very easy for something to go wrong
the vaccine not get created we see some
harmful effects and the timeline gets
pushed second we don't know yet the
efficacy of this vaccine because while
there are several companies several
trials and several different vaccines in
play we don't know yet what percentage
of the time do these vaccines actually
work that is why I'm still urging you to
socially distance to wear a mask to wash
your hands because you could be standing
next to someone who looks completely
healthy and they could potentially be
getting you sick and going even further
this topic I want to discuss something
that the w-h-o has said which has made
my blood boil the w-h-o issued this
statement last week and it confused a
lot of people take a listen from the
data we have it still seems to be rare
that an asymptomatic person actually
transmits onward to a secondary
individual this confused everybody even
doctors we were all confused as to which
research they were talking about most
people like Joe Rogan took it this way
now this comes out today it was it
basically said if you're asymptomatic
you can't transfer it as easily as they
thought it's almost impossible right so
all that worry that we worry about kids
giving it to their grandmothers they're
not gonna that was the only reason why
stores are shut down this is a prime
example of poor scientific communication
let me explain asymptomatic means
something different in technical terms
that it does to you or I this researcher
was trying to explain that those who are
asymptomatic meaning aren't showing
symptoms right now and will never show
symptoms don't usually spread kovat but
pre symptomatic patients those who are
asymptomatic right now but will get sick
later can spread Kovac quite quickly to
scientists pre symptomatic and
asymptomatic are two different terms -
you and I - the same thing the w-h-o
quickly corrected this statement and I
understood the mistake that they made it
happens as a large organization that is
general public facing they need to do a
better job at clarifying these things we
need to be able to trust a wh oh I've
consistently said on this channel to
trust the WHL YouTube pushes you to the
w-h-o anything that would go against
World Health Organization
recommendations would be a violation of
our policy so we need to not lose trust
in them and the way that we do that is
for them to avoid mistakes like this in
the future
and speaking of mistakes let's talk
about my advice on masks early on in
this pandemic here's a clip of me from
mid-february talking about masks and pay
close attention to the words that I use
the CDC has been firm on this most
people the ones that are healthy and not
sick do not need a mask at this time
notice that I approach that subject with
a level of humility I wasn't certain
that masks wouldn't help the best
evidence at the time told us that masks
wouldn't help and it was true that
however now we know something different
and that something different is just
because someone
healthy doesn't mean they can't be
spreading the virus in the beginning of
this pandemic people thought by wearing
masks they'd protect themselves so we
said no that's wrong but now we
recommend masks not to protect you the
person wearing the mask but to limit you
as a person who looks healthy from
spreading the virus into the environment
so by everyone wearing a mask were
protecting the community not the wearer
in addition in the beginning of the
pandemic we had a huge shortage of
surgical masks and 95 masks in the
hospital setting where we were working
directly with kovat 19 patients and
medical providers were dying as a result
of that I still stand by my guidance at
the time even though it wasn't accurate
it was based off the best evidence at
the time will it change yes will I be
afraid to tell you that it's changed no
because I want you to constantly be
updated looking at the most recent
research we've seen that actually
wearing masks even that cheap and
expensive surgical masks or fabric face
coverings really does limit the spread
of this specific virus that's why it
upsets me so to walk around York City
and see all these people not wearing
masks when they're in crowds of people
look if you're walking out into your
backyard and no one's there you don't
need a mask if you live in a remote area
where you're not going to run into
anybody you don't need a mess however if
you're going out to a crowded area you
have to wear a mask I'd like to also
touch on a subject that I think many
doctors and health organizations are
avoiding talking about and that's how
protests are affecting Cova 19 numbers
we can't as health care institutions go
out and say hey do not have any social
gatherings unless you're protesting
adjust cause we can't say that that's
not accurate if you have a huge social
gathering of thousands of people you're
putting your life at risk and
potentially the lives of who you will
encounter throughout your next days when
you're protesting try and keep six feet
away from others if you're gonna be
chanting or singing make sure the mask
is covering your face for the next two
weeks do your best to stay away from
vulnerable populations those over the
age of 60 or with immunocompromised
States and after you protest please
please go and get tested because the
last thing we want you to do is to be
one of those people who are asymptomatic
or pre-symptomatic and are spreading
this virus to thousands of people the
virus unfortunately doesn't care if
there are racial and Justices occurring
in this country I hate that these racial
injustice is occurring the medical
community stands
with the protests but we have to be
objective and still say that by
protesting you're putting your life at
risk
look I get it we're burnt out we've been
sitting at home for close to three
months now not being able to go do the
things that we enjoy not being able to
see our loved ones not being able to
find work and struggling to pay rent and
securing food I get it what you're
experiencing is called caution fatigue
okay there's even a medical term for it
and we in the medical community
experienced something similar called
alarm fatigue we're in the ER and
there's constant alarm bells ringing we
stopped paying attention to them and
that's a problem I think media
constantly giving you an outbreak
warning every single day telling you
that there's a new coronavirus high
number has burned you out to the point
where you tune it out and that's a
problem because I need you to stay alert
but I also need you to stay active not
anxious I recommended a couple of videos
for you here to watch and as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]